after they sent to the money they would
get a document called a guide to my new
life that included winning lottery
numbers and so this guy did this and uh
he did it so well that he was making 20
million dollars a year doing this
[Music]
what's up
dude according to the YouTube data by
the end of this sentence half the
audience will have dropped off that's
how content goes nowadays you have like
4.2 seconds to hook everybody is that
true it was is it really that short I
thought it was like a joke but it is
like that I mean like after somebody
clicks play you just see the curve start
to go Space Mountain downwards and then
uh and then it flattens out but are you
looking at the data like I I rarely log
in you just let it Flash the camera in
the first five seconds every every time
so there you go you know how like
there's a joke about news anchors
wearing like uh shorts with me
it's the sleeveless t-shirt
I'm going jacked it sleeveless tea baby
how's that for flashing foreign
I mean I don't even know what you're
prepared for you're like I can go
outside it can rain I can become a
doctor for a minute I can work out I can
climb a mountain
it's 107 degrees in Austin today and so
I'm either shirtless or sleeveless tea
most of the time when I record I got to
put the jacket on so I look a little
professional
dude I've been trying to convince Ben to
move to California from Austin I
originally pegged it at a 15 chance
what's what's it at now oh I think we're
like up to 50. I think we've made
serious Headway now I put in all this
work what I needed to do was just wait
for summer just smoke them out right all
I had to do was just smoke them out I
don't know if I ever told you this I
once was doing a deal
that required us to negotiate with a
company called Petro China Petro China
is basically like Exxon Mobil but it's
owned by the government in China
and so we go to this and they're like
the big they're like you know huge
company but it's owned by the government
so nobody knows how much it's worth all
that stuff but it's Mega powerful oil
and gas company in China so we go and
we're supposed to negotiate this deal
and I I kid you not they just they did
the opposite of smoking us out or
sweating us out they just froze us out
they put us in a room
that was like just cold as hell
and there was no way out like first
getting to the room was like a 20 minute
walk like a like a passage like going
through this Labyrinth of doors and we'd
get to this room we're in they're like
they'll be with you soon
and then they leave and seven hours pass
and we're sitting in this room and I'm
like hey I think they forgot about us
and we got to go talk to somebody and
then I tried to stand up and immediately
an arm like puts me back in the chair
they're like no no this is part of to
freeze you just yeah just to make it
uncomfortable and they're like you show
no weakness here we just sit and there's
this uh Urban myth I don't know if it's
true or not or Steve Cohen uh you know
one of the guys who apparently is based
off of uh his billions characters based
off of him Steve Cohen rich guy owns the
Mets where the reason why Patagonia
vests are popular on Wall Street is he
used to make his office freezing so when
the SEC Regulators would come in they
were really uncomfortable and everyone
knew they didn't want to stay yeah they
didn't want to stay but so apparently it
works dude I mean my Costco has a
walk-in freezer where you go get like
our walk-in fridge where you but it's a
room it's a giant room where you go get
vegetables that thing is so
uncomfortable I mean it's like
whatever's the nearest vegetable that's
all I'm getting and then I'm getting out
of there so I definitely believe it if I
was the SEC I would I would get the [__]
out of there I want to tell you about
this thing that
when people read it they probably didn't
have the same reaction as I did but I
think they should so there's this guy
it's called the greatest scam ever
written and it's about a copywriter who
ran this scam his name was Patrice
Runner and so it started basically in
the 90s where he originally saw this ad
have you ever heard of this book called
The Lazy Man's way to riches yes so I
don't remember when that originally came
out I think in the 60s but the Lazy
Man's way to riches is a really famous
ad it sold like three or four million
copies of this book
and the ad is famous amongst copywriters
because it was really successful and a
lot of the copywriting that we use now
for the internet they kind of originated
from that ad and this guy Patrice Runner
he saw this ad and he was poor and he
was like
I don't want to be poor anymore it's
pretty amazing that this guy just
convinced me to buy this book based off
of just like uh you know 20 paragraphs
of text that's amazing I want to learn
how to do that and so he did
and so we start studying copywriting and
he reads a newspaper about this lady
named like Madame Duvall Maria Duvall
was her name and basically there was a
story about her and how there was a
murder in the Caribbean and how they
couldn't find where the body is and she
was a psychic and she led the people to
where the body was
and I don't know if that's actually true
if she actually did that but it was in
the newspaper that that happened and so
he contacted her it was like look I want
to sign up create this psychic company
and I want you to be the face and I'm
going to give you five percent of
profits forever
and you really don't even need to do
anything other than like let me use your
face occasionally and that's it so she
signs up for it and he starts creating
these ads where he would mail people
these letters that looked like it was
typed out and it was from Maria Duvall
and it would use these amazing like bits
of copy so like the thing would say like
the opening line was if you've got a
special bottle of bubbly that you've
been saving for celebrating great news
now's the times now is the time to open
it up and that would be like the opening
line and it was a nine page letter that
he would send to people and he would say
like you know send me uh forty dollars
or fifty dollars and we will like uh you
you'll have good luck it was basically
like you send money and you get nothing
and then eventually it was like oh you
sent 40 we're gonna keep sending you
more letters and they would send like
two letters a day sometimes so someone
oftentimes would receive two letters and
they would send like an ad for some
vitamin that you would need to take and
recipients basically it said the
recipients were urged to reply and close
a check or money order for fifty dollars
to receive a mysterious uh bit of power
and luck in order to attract money as
and then also they would after they
accepted the money they would get a
document called a guide to my new life
that included winning lottery numbers
and so this guy did this and uh he did
it so well that he was making 20 million
dollars a year doing this and eventually
the thing ran for 10 years and it made
250 million dollars and then the
government swoops in and they're like
dude this is fraud and so now he's in
jail and he's waiting sentencing but he
might get up to life in prison so like
he's looking at like at least like 20
years of prison for this and he they
were like why'd you do this he's like I
was just so attracted to copywriting and
with writing he told the reporter this
is all from this uh an article from uh
called The Walrus it was a great article
and they show you like what the ads look
like but we'll talk about that in a
second but it goes with writing you
could get get the attention of someone
and at the end after just a few minutes
that person sends you a check to get a
project uh to get a product to an
address or a company that they've never
heard of and when I read stories like
this that should be the takeaway which
is not like this criminal is bad but how
do I use this amazing copywriting stuff
actually for good and if you click on
the article you'll see the envelopes
would have these amazing things like
we're on the back of the envelope it
would say something like um after you've
sealed this envelope we will be the only
one to have ever opened it and it says
please leave the following blank and it
says here's the day we received it
here's the time that we received it and
the recipient who's supposed to be Maria
Duvall would have to check the box in
order to like say like yep I've opened
it and they put all these little like
strange like tactics of getting someone
to convince and believe what they were
saying it's incredibly fascinating so
it's called the uh the the publication
they did the nautical on this guy it's
called The Walrus it's really good
because you should read this and think
like copywriting is amazing this guy was
a fraud obviously so that's bad well
whatever he did do that for good [__]
and it's awesome it's a really
fascinating article about this guy but
yeah now he's going to get sentenced to
like it looks like 20 years of prison
and you know who else did this this
great copywriter uh great copywriter
Gary Halbert you remember Gary Halbert
so yeah why did he go to jail I didn't
actually know it was tax tax something
yeah tax I think tax and also basically
he would sell this product I think it
was called a family
uh was it called a suit of arms what's
it called a Crest like a family crest he
would sell this product whereas like you
mail in like par and then you get mailed
back like a Crest I don't know if it's
like a graphic but he just didn't
fulfill the orders he just took the
money and like bounced it was just like
I'm easy to do that too to just give him
a Crest like yeah he just he completed
Fiverr he was just too early yeah and so
he went to prison I think for like 10
years and that's where he wrote this
really good book where it's like he
wrote letters to his son on copywriting
and that's called the letters from Boron
I guess Boron was the name of the prison
that he was in but these copywriters
it's really cool how you're able to pull
this [__] off and you by the way people
act like you can't do this anymore
because people are smarter that's not
true the 100 can still pull off all this
it's very fascinating uh I'm with you I
think this is one way that we are very
very similar where we both read these
things and have the same
sort of like uh
unexpected reaction which is some blend
of like excitement and admiration not
for the crime
but for the the tools that led to the
like you know it's the same skill it
definitely 11. it's like robbing a bank
I like I like it I like the I like what
goes in dropping that bank right um it's
like you shouldn't like the criminal in
this case but you are attracted to the
skill to the cleverness to the
um to the guile that goes into doing
something well every guy who saw Lino
DiCaprio in Wolf of Wall Street or Catch
Me If You Can was like hey Mom can I can
you give me one of your checks I want to
see if I can actually change the numbers
on it like everyone like you know what I
mean like everyone who saw that was do
the same thing or like everyone looked
up like you know Stratford Oakmont
Jordan Belford's thing after they uh
Wolf Wall Street movie like everyone's
attracted cards or whatever right now
right they're like oh I could counting
cards how does that work I could do that
you had a great bit of copy that I read
on Facebook the other day you go
there you go the more shirtless pictures
I I post the more free protein I'm sent
some asked me to some asked to pay me to
post I've never done that and I don't
intend to but here's some brands that I
use blah blah blah there you go
we may be [__] in the par household
but we're certainly not
that's so good where did you get that I
stole that from Ari Gold so uh Ari Gold
that TV show Entourage so every great
copywriter does the same thing where you
do this too you hear phrases you hear
phrases and you store them and you just
store them and so every single person
who's good at writing you have a bank
that you just we call it a swipe file
but I remember even when I was in sixth
grade watching Entourage at Sunday night
at 9 00 pm on HBO I remember hearing
that I go that's mine I'm stealing that
one
and you just wait for that perfect
opportunity to use those lines dude I
have my my it's literally called he says
he said phrases literally my sheet is
called my note is called phrases
um and I just have so many good here I
love it because what people don't know
is like phrases are really important so
I'm working on this with Hampton
actually where we're trying to create
like our Mantra or like with every type
of community it's basically a cult or
sorority where you like you need like a
phrase that summarizes it neither Crest
you need a Crest I need a Crest like I
need something and I've been like
tinkering with phrases and it's so
important to like nail a phrase and like
there's so many like really good phrases
um like for example I'm reading this
book about Martin Luther King's
assassination and he was assassinated uh
while well basically he was at this
protest for garbage workers black
garbage workers were uh were wanting to
be treated better and their phrase was
just I am and it was underlined I am a
man and like that like that one phrase
is it should be like a you know I'm not
I'm not a slave anymore I'm a man treat
me like a man and so it's like all these
phrases and I just like well see a
phrase even I remember writing that I am
a man we are mostly men
Ah that's too touchy of a subject uh
that's a whole nother thing but anyways
I love these like beautiful phrases I
love these beautiful phrases are you
workshopping a couple right now you want
to do a little live Workshop
so one that has gotten shut down but I
love it which is
CTC confidential confidentiality
transparency and commitment so CTC and
and just you gotta see so you miss one
meeting your band uh we've actually
kicked three people out already because
we've heard that they've communicated
with Outsiders of like uh some
confidential information but CTC is what
I'm trying to which is what I'm trying
to get stock make a thing yes it's not
becoming a thing as of late but yeah
well that's it that's the only one
that's
hard at work over there
it's hard because this can't be rushed
it's hard coming up with the phrase like
what are these phrases what are some
ones that you're inspired by so you said
the I am one what are some other ones
that you think are are well done well
this other one is is they're calling it
core which is like commitment openness
uh respect and uh one other thing I
don't know what the E stands for but
core and core is not sticking with me
but I'm I'm trying to be open-minded
core's not sticking with me because four
things to remember is a lot harder than
more like values then it's not like
you're uh it's like your values yeah
it's values yeah your slogan so one
thing I've been thinking about is no one
uh nothing no one never
where I was like that nothing no one
ever never which is like is This
Confidential nothing no one never dude
like yes like everything everything it's
nothing no one ever you can never talk
about what's going on so I'm pulling
around with nothing no one never I like
that one yeah yeah yeah nice uh that one
that one did a little something for me I
like that yeah did it get you going it
got me going uh what are some other
interesting ones I there's not like that
many that are intriguing to me to be
honest but I'm I'm trying to figure out
like how to do it it's really hard just
creating that shift from scratch is way
harder than it looks uh or I'm just not
talented but like are there any good
ones that you like you know the one
thing I heard about like on the value
side that always stuck with me was
um a value is useless without
acknowledging the trade-off so like you
know most companies when they do their
kind of like values they'll be like
respect honor integrity which is stupid
because like what's the opposite is that
of course yeah like you said nothing
that's of Interest you've acknowledged
no like uh sacrifice in that you and
it's just generic and so it's not
memorable it's not memorable it's not
useful because it's like um
it's just an of course type of statement
whereas uh you know Facebook did one
that that stuck which was move fast and
break things it's beautiful
and move faster break things was so good
and the reason why was because it
acknowledged the downside of moving fast
and sometimes you're going to break [__]
and like
they said yeah yes we take that we will
we'll err on the side of that we'll we
will take that trade off and so
um I think that values are only useful
when you acknowledge
when you when they bake into it the
opinionated
trade-off right like that the fact that
yep there there are pros and cons to
this and our opinion is that this is the
pro that matters right um and and that
we're down we we will live with this
downside because that big because that's
what shows you what you value like for
example
um
if you're somebody who's really high
integrity
you're gonna
um
you're gonna let's say there's you know
opportunity to take you're gonna not
take you're gonna have to sacrifice
things that could go your way because
you're high integrity this is like
Michelle Obama had one that that kind of
was yeah it's gotta be like painfully
truthful painfully true exactly so she
did the when they go low we go high
which is like kind of acknowledges that
like you all they go low it hurts you
want to hit them back but no we go high
right when they go low we go hard that's
another example of one that's like I
like I don't know when she said that but
that's like more than five years ago I
still remember that a lot of people
repeated that
kind of like to make fun of her but it
was politics people make fun of
everything but like I do think there was
something in that that was like more
real than just like we stand for respect
it's like Okay cool so it doesn't mean
anything to anybody when you say that
it's like we're all numb to those sorts
of things like Subway eat fresh and we
print grill marks onto our chicken
because it's not really grilled like you
know it's like all right well
that's what they should really say it's
like
looks fresh but it ain't you know we uh
my high school had a great one that I've
always remembered it was meant for we
were in all boys school and it was meant
for others and they just did such a good
job of like nailing that into our brains
just you got to be a man for others
there's like that's gonna be a dating
app too yeah
you're right uh
uh so I remember meant for others I like
that but it's been really challenging so
I guess I gotta go find some more
phrases
um
but but uh yeah I gotta I gotta I gotta
make that better do you have any that
you use for any of your companies you
none of your was what was milk Rose did
milk Road have one
no but uh I don't think you need one at
the beginning by the way at the
beginning I don't think you need one I
think you do need certain North Stars
like you know you started the hustle you
were like
um we call it both [__] free news
yeah you were like this is like your
no-nonsense or no [__] your your
smart friend telling you what happened
in a no [__] way that was a really
good like North Star guiding principle
that you could just say Okay cool so
like we stole a version of that for the
milk road because what would what ended
up happening here's like a tactical way
that that started to drift the top story
in all the news news things would have
been about like some arbitrary [__]
like some
um maybe it was like a regulatory thing
or maybe it was like like a kind of a
boring regulatory thing or it was like
some Layer Two blockchain on uh on like
some layer 2 protocol on top of some
like obscure blockchain did this thing
and we would write about it and I would
read it because at this point I was like
you know I was like the editor it really
never was the writer for milk Road
um but I would read it and I would just
call Ben and I'd be like
dude what like are you interested in
this he's like well not really but I
mean they seem to be like I mean it's a
top story
by other news Alice I was like cool but
like if you weren't into it like I was
like here's the time would you text me
about this like would you text me and
tell me about this and would I be
interested this is already baked into
you wouldn't even text me if you didn't
know if you you would only text me if
you knew I'd be interested so I was like
let's just use that as the test like the
litmus test is basically
would you text me about this thing that
happened
um if I was like yeah what's new in
crypto right now like if that's not the
thing then don't put it in the
newsletter even if other people are
writing about it and when we made that
shift all of the like metrics kind of
went up because people just naturally
would resonate with that better because
um we had like a guiding principle for
what what goes in and what goes out and
I think that's the other thing that goes
that's really useful is
um it's really easy to talk about what
goes in what's important is to say what
goes out and I do this with like
strategy planning documents too like if
I like I wrote up a strategy for our
econ business
I think everybody should do something
like this by the way I wrote it down I
wrote here's the six bets that we have
made this year we're making this year
and I write them down first so for
example I wrote the things called Big
bets and I share this document with
everyone I said big bet number one was
um we didn't have anybody in like demand
planning or inventory forecasting I was
like it's pretty stupid that we don't
have everybody anybody doing this
because of that
I think we have a ton of waste and we're
Miss like sometimes we're way under on
products that people want sometimes
we're way over and it just sits there
and just ties up our cash I think that
if we hire somebody who's got experience
doing this we will get 20 30 Improvement
on the bottom line literally just from
that one Higher that's bet number one
and then we hire that person now we're
seeing how it plays out at number two
was like that's smart um let's say like
uh whatever without giving too much away
let me say
um
like uh part like this this type of
partnership we're trying to go for this
type of partnership
um with this other big entity we believe
that if we do that it's going to have
this effect that's the bet we're making
we'll know if it's successful if x
happens I just wrote that wrote this
down and so the whole Strat company
strategy for the year is one page long
and it's just six like sentences it's
like
here's the situation here's the BET
here's the situation here's the BET and
I just wrote that out new and then with
that at the bottom I wrote and here's
the bets we are not making that we
otherwise reasonably could have so for
example we're not launching on Amazon
because if you're because even though
that would clearly add to the bottom
line but if we're launching on Amazon
that's gonna take resources away and see
those other six bets that's going to
take all of our attention this year so
we're saying no to that we're saying no
to this other thing we're saying no to
this other thing all of which were
totally reasonable you could make a case
for but we decided not to do them
because we don't want to spread
ourselves too thin and it was actually
that not doing section like the first
part was useful but the second part was
even more useful and I think that people
should should highlight those like
you know it's not focus is not what you
say yes to focus is the 100 good ideas
you say no to and so I think when you
take that principle and you apply it
that that's where you find the
interesting stuff like whether it's in
your company marketing or whatever what
are you calling that
in e-commerce Playbook oh I just like
the bets like big bets that's what I
call it like what are the big effects
that we're making this year and we'll
see it I wrote it I also wrote the top
like
we don't think that all of these are
going to pan out the way we expect
what are you right now I wrote one or
two are going to either fail or we won't
even execute on because one or two
winners will suck up a bunch of our
energy I expect that to happen I expect
the middle for to work
maybe you know plus or minus 20 on how
well we think they should work so like
some will slightly underperform our
expectations some will slightly over
perform
one or two of the six bets will either
fail completely or we won't execute well
enough because our attention got sucked
away by the other ones and one or two
should have a huge payoff that's the
distribution if we if they all just work
as expected we didn't really bet wildly
enough right so I kind of like the goals
thing that you don't want to hit 100 of
your goals you want to hit maybe like 70
of your goals that shows that you
stretched far enough without
overstretching I uh by the way speaking
of the milk Road I had I forgot to ask
you this so
and uh
right now so basically in 2017 I wrote
this ad for the hustle and it was my
boss thinks I'm smart parentheses I'm
not
it's because I read the hustle and he
has no idea that it exists Dash a reader
of the hustle and that was like our ad
on Facebook
on Twitter I see that ad everywhere for
every newsletter for every like AI where
it was like my boss thinks I know about
AI I don't the reason I what happened is
you did it morning Brew then did it so
they called did they do it it's someone
who's been running an ad like that for a
long time
um so you if you've seen those ads
you're like oh good idea I'll copy that
then the other thing was uh Facebook
launched the ad Library so now you can
go see other companies ads so you can
just go and look what uh what ads are
they running Google launched an ad
Library Tick Tock now launched an ad
Library so you can go see anyone's Tick
Tock ads too
then you've talked about that ad on the
podcast and I noticed after the after
you said on the podcast then people
started running it then there's also a
guy who worked for you who worked for up
for us at milk Road who then goes in
he's pitching up he's basically going
and telling every newsletter company I'm
the key to the growth of the hustle of
milk Road of every [__] newsletter
company I did it I'm the best
um I could tell you exactly what they
did
and um I don't know about you for the
Hustle but for us I'm like this guy is
massively overstating what he did but
like whatever I mean I guess we were
already in the we already had a million
subscribers but yeah I mean and I didn't
work closely with them but I I'm sure
he's great I just uh we were okay but he
is definitely overselling and he is
people will come to me and they'll be
like
um hey I just wanted to get a quick
reference check this guy basically like
he does a presentation sales deck that
just says like
I did everything for milk Road like I I
figured it all out I did all these
things and like is that legit and I'm
like no and actually the funny thing is
I think in the short term that helped
him as a long term that hurt him because
two very big names have come to me and
they said hey I'm thinking behind this
guy sounds like he did great work for
you guys just want to do a quick pulse
check like
um thumbs up thumbs down would you
recommend and I was like
I wish I could say yes but like no for
these two reasons one
he's overstating what he did if he just
said what he did it would have been fine
uh two when we sold the company he went
and put up a Twitter thread saying like
hey milk Road sold and here's all the
things that they do to to grow
and we asked somebody like hey man can
you take that down like we're still
running as a business like you can't
just you shouldn't just like you're a
you're a service provider you're you're
a contractor for us yeah yeah we're a
client of yours we never said and you
want your confidentiality you should
never go publish all of your clients
things or even it's not actually all but
like we don't want any of this stuff out
there right and um and he's like no I
gotta get mine too from the sale and I'm
like what like dude I'm asking you to
take this down are you really gonna like
your client so it was never deleted and
he was he tried to say no again and I
was like wow like Jesus that is like
insanely unprofessional to do that
um in my opinion at least and uh you
know so whatever he did delete it after
that after I was like wow are you like
are you serious this is actually the
stance you're gonna take that's an
insane stance to take yeah I don't like
when people talk about two two really
big names that I think would have been
like way bigger than the hustle way
bigger than milk Road we're gonna work
with him have asked me and I'm like I
can't I'm just gonna tell you what my
experience was you decide and they're
like oh no we would not want to work
with somebody who does that and I was
like damn like the short term that hurts
leads to long-term loss unfortunately
like
you know that's the the irony of of
doing stuff like that and I've done
stuff like that too where I make a
short-term short-term good decision
that actually cost me in the long run
but it's hard to see in the moment you
know so it's it's yeah that's a that's a
that's an expensive lesson but my
question was were you running this ad
and did it still work up until we sold
it was still working we didn't run that
ad we didn't run my boss things on
whatever
um we did I think try a version of like
my friends think I'm uh
you know like whatever my friends think
I I know everything about crypto what
they don't know is that I just read the
milk wrote Every Morning
um something like that I think we ran
that but those weren't High perform like
that wasn't the highest performer or
other we had other stuff that was better
performers but um that was our best one
more than 50 of our subscribers were
organic so
it does like you know you you know the
if more than 50 of your growth comes
organic then that that means it's the
content that's the content the brand
dude I've talked to so many of these new
newsletter guys and they're all doing so
when we when we started the hustle like
up into hundreds of thousands were
organic and then we like learned I
didn't know what paid marketing was then
we learned about it and then we started
doing this thing called co-registration
which
it would typically only scammy marketer
type of people would do that like people
selling like sex pills and [__] and we
were like well that's interesting like
in theory let's actually figure out what
it means in a non-schemy way and so we
like well explain it so you go to a site
so for example
um you go to uh I'll try to find a real
life example go to if you go to bold.org
it's a website where you can apply
uh you can enter in your information and
it automatically applies you to tons and
tons of different scholarships
um and what it says was great if you
want somehow they have a point system
where it's like it's free to use but you
have to sign up for like these
newsletters in order to be able to
um in order to be able to apply to even
more scholarships and so we would pay
bold.org
some money I don't remember the money
one dollar let's say for every college
kid who entered their email and sent to
the hustle and then they would go and
subscribe to more stuff uh more
scholarships and so that's what co-reges
so you're registering for one thing
but then you are asked to register for
another thing in exchange for some type
of perk
typically that that's an internet
marketing hack that's done with scammy
stuff really scammy people but we went
to product hunt and we were like hey
have you guys thought about doing co-reg
I'm like yeah we're working on it we're
like well that would be great we would
be your first customer and so that's how
we started growing really quickly or we
were already growing quickly but once
you you know we're adding like we're
adding like 5 000 people a day reinvent
that every every stage right at the
beginning you do friends friends and
family then you do your own social media
then you do uh posts that are really
good content that's going to go viral
that's gonna get you now to the next
level of organic then you start layering
on some paid then you have to diversify
your paid because not one source is
going to work as well as the others and
they you know they don't all scale right
and when you're adding a hundred
thousand people a month you have like 50
or some amount is still organic but then
that's still like 80 000 customers that
you need to sign up so some will be
Facebook some of this some that some
co-reg So Co reg worked really well the
problem with it is that it's a very low
intent reader so like the scholarship
person isn't like the highest is like
hey Sean sign up for milk Road it's
awesome that's high intent lesson less
high but still high is like oh I saw
this ad on Facebook saying there's this
newsletter that sounds cool I'm
interested the lowest intent is I'm
trying to buy a uh I'm trying to get a
coupon for Target but I have to get
enter in the I have to get my email yeah
in order that's the lowest intent or I'm
trying to win this free prize and I get
more entries if I just sign up for this
[__] newsletter whatever I'll sign up
for it that's the lowest intent now I
talk to well but that but the the thing
is is that you grow quickly so for a
quarter you can get an email subscriber
but for every 10 email subscribers only
one will actually be of high quality and
so the problem is is you get addicted to
this and so I was talking to all these
other newsletter guys and they're like I
got to 100 000 in like six months I'm
like oh sick how they go oh this thing
called Co reg and I'm like oh you're
[__] this is a horrible newsletter
you're [__] this is a your business is
done by the way there's there's other
versions of this so sub stack has a
thing where you subscribe to someone
substack and then they're like here's
five other sub actually my like Auto
checked and you're just you're just
trying to continue and now you're
subscribed to five newsletters and you
see people whose curve on substack looks
Flats up like you know normal growth
normal good growth normal good growth
and then like hockey stick it's like yes
I crossed 300 000 500 000 subscribers
it's like yeah but these aren't people
who actually want to read your thing and
then the other thing is that they think
the open rate is high but open rates
nowadays because of the way they've
changed with apple cookie stuff works
it's it's not reliable so for example
yeah when we started 40 was good when we
started 40 was good that was considered
the best and then 50 we would get 50 and
we were like we're the greatest there is
now everyone is 50 right and because
it's because they're not actually 50
it's because open rates cannot be
measured the same way they used to be
able to be measured where it was more
more reliable now you have to use
click-through rate or whatever uh like
are people actually clicking your your
ads your content that sort of thing and
so uh this guy that I was talking I was
talking about for the milk Road he was
the one who's like oh yeah co-red who
should do this we were like okay let's
try it let's see how it goes we tried it
sure enough
sure enough you get you get good growth
out of it but and you get addicted to it
but it's the quality so after we sold we
were like hey let's you know like at
some point we were like okay let's look
at all these sources we're getting this
organic we're getting this from here
this from here we did an analysis
and we're like all right let's test this
coverage thing the open rates look good
let's just uh let's how do we figure out
if these are high quality or not like I
don't know open rates are good the cost
is good should be fine right
we sent him an email he said uh Hey just
wanted to blah blah you know if if you
read the milk grow do you like it like
just respond with like whatever hello
you know tell me where you're like hey
you're a subscriber to the milk Road
where do you live yeah we want to know
where you live if somebody actually
reads your daily newsletter 50 of the
time they're so excited to get an email
from the founder that says you know hey
I'm just reached out to say whatever
they'll give a very high reply rate
guess how many replies we got I have no
idea
I think we literally got three replies
out of how many cents there was maybe
like I don't know I want to say like 20
000 or something like that like twenty
thousand and three replied it was it was
like a big number yeah I don't know the
exact but like I know that the reply
number was something like three replies
that day maybe more trickled in but like
it doesn't matter that day three people
replied and we were like oh cut this off
immediately
um and that same guy goes and he peddles
that to all the other newsletters it's
like yeah this is what the hustle did
this one velcro did it does it's like we
did with a small percentage of what we
were doing and as soon as we were able
to test it we were like oh screw this
why would we want a subscriber number
like stupid somebody you don't want a
subscriber number that's not real right
like real subscribers the only way to
build a real business and uh you know I
talked to the morning Brew guys and I
think they're they're also very like
they I think just straight measure on
like what does this lead to in terms of
clicks on our ads yeah like or like
conversions even you know from how many
people buy our advertisers buying
something right like if you because if
I'm if I'm getting you as a customer
that's the right way to do it right
that's the sustainable way to do it but
I don't think people you know kids these
days they're doing it differently than
than back in our day one one year ago
yeah I remember way back then six months
ago no that that's how they have to do
it and they also um another thing is I
talked to another guy and I was like
well of your list how many if you said
that you're hosting an AI event that was
free uh how many people are gonna show
up he's like oh we'd sell out
immediately I'm like great then you're
doing that that sounds like you're doing
it correctly and then I talked to
another guy I'm like well how many
people would show up to this event and
they're like well no one I'm like wow
well then this this business sucks like
they're they're not they're not real uh
you should bail and quit uh or start
over uh but yeah the co-reg thing it's
mostly nonsense it doesn't always have
to be or you could uh it's kind of a
pain in the ass if you make money
through advertising it's like you need
to hit a Top Line number and that's why
I hate advertising is because there's
very there's inverse incentives so like
not everyone's aligned with the same
thing and so I think that's why I
[__] hate advertising uh it could be
done well but when you have like a team
to support and you want Katie to hit her
quota and get paid I'm like ah [__] you
gotta like make sacrifices and I hate
that but anyway I wanted to bring up
this ad because we're talking about
copywriting but
it is what it is
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
on Friday I interviewed Laird Hamilton
how did it go so it went really bad uh
it went very bad
it went bad uh
well he's not a business guy for one but
I'm like a fitness I'm into fitness and
stuff but I wanted to ask him all the
fitness stuff but I was like I don't I
watched so many hours of him leading up
to it
and I was like I don't want to just ask
the same questions like I just watched
so much of your stuff that all the
questions that I thought I was going to
have you've already answered them yeah
you've answered it and so there was like
that that there but also
dude I just think it's a bummer to meet
your Heroes because he's amazing but I
just want him to be this like idea
rather than this reality do you know
what I mean I like I like him so like I
remember like I I just I've been very
lucky to meet a bunch of my heroes and
once you meet them they're a little bit
less of it here a hero and I think I
just prefer them being a hero not to say
that he didn't live up to my
expectations he did it was just that uh
I don't want to be even remotely appear
of his I want him to be like you know
right my great grandpa who I've read
heard stories about if you're a fan of
this podcast if you consider me a Sam
you know somebody that you look up to in
any way prepare to be disappointed all
right we're just very average people
when you meet us we will destroy we will
ruin this podcast for you but I was
super self-conscious about it so if you
guys hear the Pod let me know like in
the YouTube comments what you think but
it was it was only okay I think it was
maybe it was only okay for me as because
I was in interviewing him but I just
learned so much about him and I'm like
oh I already know everything there's
nothing new to know about you or I'm
just not unique enough to ask a question
you should have shifted gears and gone
Bobby altaf on him
what's that oh uh like that girl awkward
interview girl and just act like you
don't care she has shot up so basically
I saw her on Tick Tock and I the thing
about Tick Tock and Instagram is you
don't know who else knows what you're
watching right uh like it's hard like
there's no like chart or there's no like
Greatest Hits and so I was just like who
is this random chick popping up
uh is interviewing these these guys when
she's like in her bed interviewing like
Drake like not just like then I saw
Drake and I'm like what the hell what is
going on with this how is this like just
this 21 year old woman who's like rude
to her guest talking to Drake and then
on the podcast charts I think she was
number one for a few days yeah she's
been in the top five she went from
I've never heard of this person and she
didn't have a podcast too a top five
podcast in like two weeks so we're doing
something wrong
well yeah for sure she has this ad for
seat geek sea geek advertised on her
podcast with Drake and she was like so
today's sponsor is sea geek which makes
sense because Drake apparently hosts
events and I think sea geek lets you buy
tickets for events so if you like events
and parade
yeah
yeah and she goes and they give you
twenty dollars cool
like that's her ad so the the call to
action was the best she said something
like she was like
to go
um you can use Street geek if you want I
guess
[Laughter]
dude it's so funny she's pretty good I
don't want to listen to 60 Minutes of
that interview but like
so she's interviewing Drake which is
like I think her the first podcast that
came out and she's like in the middle of
it she's like
I don't I don't know any other questions
do you do you have any other questions
and he's like uh not really like
weren't they in bed under the covers
during the interview yeah they're in a
bed which is just I mean she's a genius
clearly so she's a genius so I think her
story is she was like a mom she was like
a mommy tick tocker
but I don't really understand how she
went from Mommy tick tocker
to
podcaster interviewing Drake with like a
really clear brand that's amazing like a
very distinct Style
that's amazing because if you watch her
tick tocks she doesn't talk like that
yeah it's just a character she's or she
doesn't I mean it's not like I don't
think her Tick Tock is mainly like that
like I'm gonna put one up right now but
like no some of it was it's like normal
or her joking around with her friends
but no it's it's like Stephen Colbert
but instead of this conservative guy
it's the I don't give a [__] type of
person so she uh I watched like an hour
straight of one of these podcasts I
rarely listened to like if you tell me
hey there's a new podcast like I need 10
people to recommend a podcast before I
go try it you know what I mean like it's
not like an easy ask
but um yeah I got hooked on her [__]
really quickly and watched a hour-long
awkward interview with her and Mark
Cuban and her with Rick Glassman I don't
know if you saw this but she did one
with Rick Glassman and it didn't seem
like he was in on the joke
I think he was actually the first one
that she recorded
Rick glassman's a comedian oh got it
yeah yeah yeah he might have been
another joke because he's like a very
talented guy like he could
he could find that line where it looks
like he's not in on the joke but he is
um
but she was just like uh I mean she's
just awkwardly interviewing him and he
at some point he's just like
what is like what is this why are you
doing this and she's like why am I doing
what I'm interviewing you and he's like
no but you're he's like you're saying
that you're interviewing me but
everything I say you just
say is a lie why would I lie why would I
come to your podcast and lie and she's
like I don't know why are you lying and
then he's like he's like I'm not lying
is this your bit is this what you do and
he's like he just can't figure it out
he's like I'm sorry I was frustrated and
defensive because I felt like you were
trolling me or something I didn't
understand what was happening I still
don't really understand what's happening
but I'm gonna do better to try to answer
your questions and she's like thank you
you were being mean and he's like I
wasn't being mean I was reacting I want
to know what happens before and after
the interview because after like so you
and I have done some stuff in person
with people and like you're really cool
and friendly enough to people but I
don't know what you do afterwards like
particularly with like a Tucker Carlson
interview where he's like getting mean
with people and like you shake hands
afterwards and say thanks for coming you
know what I mean Lord or just like does
it does it that was terrible thank you
that was that yeah like oh we dislike
each other strongly yeah so I'm curious
to see what like the perform where she's
like and seen and does she like be
friendly and like give him a hug I I I
don't I would like to see what that
before and after is like
yeah I I don't know she's a mystery to
me somebody explained this to me I I
just don't understand who she is how she
landed such big guess why she
immediately is so popular I mean like I
get her brand but like how did she even
break out that's kind of what I don't
get
um but whatever follow me all tough good
good for you Bobby altaf 25 years old I
think 20 25 26 years old and uh
like clearly going to be one of the most
famous podcasters
all right yeah [__] us
yeah I mean that's the third time that's
happened or the second time it happened
with the caller daddy woman uh where
like it was like episode two she shot up
there that's pretty rare I mean it's
more common with YouTube with podcasts
that that doesn't happen
often at all uh right now someone's
gonna do that obnoxious tweet where it's
like
everybody thinks Bobby altoff is an
overnight success here's how it was 10
years in the making and then it's just
gonna be like you know
some stupid origin story that like
really wasn't like she actually is kind
of an overnight success yeah which is
cool I like should be some right there
should be some people talk about like
they don't exist I'm like well Instagram
is only two years old I mean like those
are real like it's real
um which which one of these things you
want to go to all right
um dating so you and I both happily
married off the daily Market but shit's
getting crazy in the dating world I
don't know if you've seen these two
things I'm going to tell you about
the first one is called chaos singles
party have you ever heard of this no do
you download the dating apps now just to
like check it out and see what it's
about
if my wife asks this just just for
science no no of course no I bought all
these but I read this is the New York
Times so
um I heard I read this story in the New
York Times and I was like what this
sounds fascinating so here's the story
this woman Cassidy Davis is on the
dating app she's just a normal person
um and it's Valentine's Day 2022 so last
year Valentine's Day she's frustrating
she doesn't doesn't have anything to do
on Valentine's so she just basically
she's like hey here's what's what we
should do we should throw like a singles
party on Valentine's Day so if you're
single on Valentine's Day come to this
she tells every one of her girlfriends
who's also struggling with online dating
hey match with someone on Tinder and
then invite them to this party invite
them to a house party
and they're like what and she's like
yeah just match with one person and
invite them as your plus one to this
house party but everybody's gonna do it
so it would be just a bunch of single
people at this party and she's like all
right so they they try to do it she at
the last minute is like I don't know if
anyone's gonna come so she invites 65
guys from Tinder to be like come and
they're like what is happening is this
real are you like catfishing me she's
like dude just get the Como don't come
all right that's it and so she has this
house party and you can see the video on
her on her Tick Tock but it's like a
very which city I'm not sure where this
one was but it's a small it was like a
small thing it looked like maybe there
was like 20 people there but they were
kind of having fun so it was like a
bunch of single young people playing
like drinking games whatever she records
she makes a tick tock out of it stitches
it together like just the highlights of
the party basically posted on Tick Tock
and says what she did she goes she's
like I did the most chaotic thing
possible for Valentine's Day I invited
I told all my girlfriends to match with
someone on Tinder and invite them to my
house for this house party
and it was awesome and then people that
thing explodes that video gets like
whatever
tons of views and the concept people
really like this concept and so she's
like I'm gonna do another one so she
posts an update she's like I'm gonna do
another one in two or three weeks puts a
link up for the chaos singles party same
rules is it free
um I think it might have been free or
maybe there's a cover charge I'm not
sure
500 people show up to that one and since
then for the last year and a half of
This Woman's life she's just been going
on the road traveling City to City she
partnered up with Tinder they like
promote this thing now in the app
they'll even promote her her parties
um and she gets paid to basically host
these things and now 200 300 people a
night come to these singles parties same
rules match with one that's your plus
one come to this event you can mix and
mingle you can you can stick with the
person you invited or just whatever it's
all just people on Tinder who want to
like
have this chaos singles party I love
this idea this is awesome I'm looking at
her Tick Tock now so well done by her
and now these things are like big like
they're they're partnering with like
legit venues it like looks like a lot of
fun it looks like a whole whole scene
now this is awesome I'm looking at her
Tic Tac This Woman's talented did I tell
you about the or did you ever see the
Twitter things that I used to do for
dating sometimes
yeah those were great it was they were
great my friend right it was basically
like it was Thanksgiving and uh we were
having friends over and some of them are
single and I'm like they were like hey
can you post me on your Twitter I want
uh they asked or you said it because
that's a crazy ass one of the people
made a joke they're like dude just post
me on your Twitter I need to meet a guy
or someone it was like one of Sarah's
friends was like I need to meet a nice a
nice guy who's successful can you like
introduce me I was like I'm just gonna
post you on Twitter and then I was like
well I don't want to make you the only
person like I'm your pimp so I'm gonna
get 10 friends and the Twitter said the
Tweet said um
um hope you're hungry on Thanksgiving
Day uh you know like here's 10 people 10
of my buds yeah I was like hope you're
hungry meet my friend Jesse yeah here's
10 here's 10 of my friends who are
single and I said like a little bit
about what they do for work and just I
just went on their Instagram and took a
picture and um it got viewed like two
million times and I got dm'd by a lot of
Brands like hey you want to make this a
thing we'll sponsor it I was like no
that's not gonna be my thing I don't
want that no I was just [__] around
and I think that that could potentially
work like we actually turned it into
like a uh like where it's like an
affluent crowd dating app or something
like that I think I I did it with
Jonathan and Jonathan actually met a
girl who he went out with I think like a
handful of times like so for Jonathan I
think it was successful is this true
what happened after you got posted on
this thing well one of the girls who
applied uh shout out to Connor Anne she
came to the uh South by Meetup that we
did so I got to meet her there hung out
a little bit
um but in terms of like my DMs like I
got hit up by a gay dude and this nice
Indian woman who I
um decided not to reply super successful
yeah but for her and for for the women
I'm sure it crushed
are you still seeing that girl Connor
are you guys just buddies now
um nah not really she lives in Florida
so but it kind of worked yeah
we're grasping for straws I mean pretty
successful sounds like
these gorilla things I love by the way I
love these like gorilla gorilla dating
yes so here's another one date me docs
have you have you heard about this trend
so it's date me dot directory is that
the URL that's the that's the directory
of them but date me docs is like
basically you take instead of going on a
dating app you created a Google doc and
you just write in long form
all about you your story what you want
who you are what you're into what you're
not into where your boundaries are all
that stuff you just make a very detailed
Google doc and that's your profile and
then somebody created the directory
that links all the people like it's like
an air table table so it'd be like you
know here's you know um Christina she's
a female she's interested in men she's
age 42 and it's just literally an air
table and um dude they're all Sally they
put mono and Polly they're like it looks
like almost half of them are poly yeah I
mean they want to have an open
relationship or they're not serious
kids these days don't I think it's like
oh I think they want to like be dating a
bunch of people at once or something I
think it's like half of them are poly
that's wild to me yeah yeah that's I
think um you know that's that's
something that's changed I think since
we were like when I was dating 10 years
ago
I never met anybody who was like you
know I'm polyamorous
yeah the only people who did that are
like are like um it's like a guy who's
got like 10 wives and it's on the TLC
Channel it comes on after John and Kate
Plus Eight yeah yeah
this is uh I think that's new so anyways
the these docs if you look at these
click click into some of these docs they
put your photos and stuff and like a
huge bio this is wild I click this one
uh that's by Misha it's the fourth one
down so Misha is a male and it takes two
to a website that there's just like
these like torches like you're entering
a dungeon probably not the vibe Misha
that you want but here we go and then
the title is just romance hi I'm
currently single looking for a primary
partner hot that's hot how you said that
primary partner like that
um only been in other relationships just
bought a house blah blah blah
um and then it's like here's a bunch of
my favorite blog posts here's some of my
first dates you can chat with me on
Discord here's my Spotify here's some
pictures of me a bunch of pictures boom
boom boom all right so that's that's
Bishop but like one of the things I
noticed I clicked through a bunch of
these is how
intellectual all of these are so they'll
be like
you know
things you don't normally put on a
dating profile it'd be like like here's
one I'm on This Woman's uh page uh srida
she says
um I'm not ideologically monogamous
meaning I don't think monogamy is
innately superior to polyamory I hold
romantic feelings for more than one
person at once but also struggle with
jealousy blah blah it's like very
it's like is this therapy what is this
this is like a whole like open book
style of letting somebody into your
brain which I can definitely see working
for some people and I can see it totally
not working for a type for the type of
person who they don't want out so I
actually think this is a really great
idea because I think it attracts in a
lot of the same type of person the kind
of like
a little bit overly intellectual very
open-minded type of crowd that would be
attractive you know it's kind of tech
tech focused uh crowd here
oh my gosh this is wild smiling it was
just literally he's looking at a screen
and he's just smirking I'm looking at a
lot of this uh it's there's one guy he's
got a 15 page user manual any like
documents his whole life to explain how
to like and he talks about like ethical
stuff he's like the correct answer to
the trolley problem is to kill one
person to save five
like he like there is a correct like
this is wild and on some regard I'm like
well if you're like a single woman who's
like 30 and you're like look I just need
to meet like a competent man who's like
thoughtful I guess this is the way to go
unfortunately
these aren't the type of guys that
typically like can woo a woman I'm on a
dock right now and it just there's a
whole sub subsection called child
rearing plans and then it's 17
paragraphs of their plans for child
rearing this is pre-first date which is
kind of amazing so have you heard of um
this reminds me of two things one if you
uh there's this guy named Christian uh
Rudder I think his name is he founded
OkCupid he was one of the three or four
co-founders and he had a Blog on all the
data that OkCupid had and so and then
eventually turned it into a book and the
thing was basically like you say one
thing but your actions on our dating app
say another thing like you say you want
x y and z
and I think one of the big takeaways was
you say you want this this and this
you really just go after people's photos
so like you say you don't want to you
you say you don't want a smoker but if
they're hot enough you'll you'll go with
a smoker you say you don't want an
animal lover but if they like fit your
like your physical wants you're gonna
You're Gonna Wanna be with them and like
that always intrigued me and that's why
I don't think some of these like
long-form things will actually work I
think they want it to work but it won't
the other thing is have you heard about
the league do you remember the dating
app the league yeah she came on the Pod
once yeah her name is Amanda Bradford
she's a buddy of mine she sold the lead
you know they sold the league
I didn't know this all day so they sold
it yes I believe it was a very good sale
they sold it to match I think match.com
or one of the big ones and I asked why
they bought it and she was like well
basically we only had like five or ten
employees or something at the league it
was a really small team
but the league originally I don't know
if it started out as the phrase ivy
league but it was basically like
high-end to meet a high-end partner and
you had to like apply and stuff like
that and she was like one day I just
said I went to she's a developer
um and she goes I logged into like our
our app store account and I was like
we're charging 20 bucks a month right
now how high does the App Store let me
charge like what's the highest amount
for subscription revenue and I think I
think it was like 99 a week she's like
that's the highest I go [__] it that's
what we're gonna do we're just gonna do
99 a week and she was like everyone at
my company and everyone outside said
it's not gonna work she's like it
crushed it we our Revenue went up like
crazy and one of the biggest reasons why
match bought us is they're like we need
to figure out how to sell products that
are hundreds of dollars a month and no
one knows how and she's like oh I'll
teach you how
all you do is you go to your the App
Store and you just delete the number
that you put in and you just put the
higher number and guess what people are
still gonna do it and that was like her
thing was that it was a really really
expensive dating app and it totally
worked uh for for higher end people
and so I still think that could be cool
what you and I didn't have when we were
younger when we were dating we probably
wouldn't have qualified then and we are
and unfortunately we're not uh we can't
use it now but basically have you heard
of Raya yeah it's like a celebrity it's
like you gotta be hot and famous to be
in or something like that yeah I think
they just look at your Instagram like if
you're verified on Instagram you're
allowed to do it so Raya is like
everyone who's single is like saying
like oh of course we know all about it
but Raya is cool but I like these uh
like exclusive dating apps and these
expensive ones I think it's way better
I've Got Friends that run uh Tinder
competitors and it sounds like a
horrible business it's one of the very
few businesses where
you can't be like number three or number
four like there's basically number one
and number two and that's it at least
that's what it appears like if you're
going for Mass Market what's the quotes
like you know I don't want to be a part
of any club that will have me as a
member that's that's sort of what you
want when it comes to dating or cool
things
um you know this date me docs thing I
think is a really fun idea I'm glad uh
whoever I don't know who created this
but kind of kind of like a cool cool
idea and obviously like things like this
have been around for a long time right
like Indian people famously like this is
how my parents got married for example
you write in the newspaper like you're
you're like bio data it's like your your
name your age your job your whatever and
you just create this profile that's like
text only and people are like cool
married let's do it and um you know
that's basically how things how things
work so you know stuff like this
actually can work
the funny thing is
um
this is actually you know what I'm gonna
actually do I'm actually just gonna
recruit on here I think this is a great
recruiting platform I think these people
are probably all really smart thoughtful
individuals who are tech savvy a lot of
developers on here they put their GitHub
profile yeah [__] LinkedIn I'm just
I'm scraping this for leads to hire from
this is amazing uh uh dude this one guy
on here says 16 years old that's a trap
Jack I'm not clicking back
I've seen way too many episodes of Chris
Hanson I'm not clicking that I know
straight to the FBI website bro the next
phrase here is uh come on
Folsom Prison yeah dude my first one of
my first internet companies was called
bunk and the premise was we would put
these ads we would uh
so close to the next Airbnb well it
should have been Airbnb and it should
have been just Tinder for Tinder but it
basically the way it started was we
would go and find online three and four
bedroom apartments and we would like if
it was a four bedroom apartment for four
grand we would say we have one bedroom
available for one thousand dollars and
we would get 500 people to apply and
then we would host a party and team up
people to get that place as well as a
bunch of other places because we're like
oh you guys are all looking for similar
budgets apparently so just like come and
team up and get your own apartment
and uh it worked it worked quite well
and then a bunch of the people at the
party started like hooking up with each
other and we didn't catch the clue that
we should have just made this a dating
thing and then we launched this app we
called it roommates and it was basically
Tinder for roommates and again we didn't
catch the clue that people like I
actually met a girl two different girls
on that app uh that I ended up dating in
2013 or 14. and again we didn't catch
the clue we should have just done this
for dating it would have worked a lot
better
yeah the dating game is changing you
know one thing that dating is always
going to be a problem like it will never
not be a pain point for people like No
And there's no such thing as sort of
like solving dating and anytime one
thing gets popular it creates the need
for another so like you know Tinder
created the need for something like
hinge and now when you have sort of like
the Tinder and hinge generation I talk
to people who are dating now and they're
like oh you know what the two worst
things about those PL like about Tinder
and hinge is like you get either on
Tinder you just get bots like business
is just girls trying to get you to like
subscribe to their only fans like oh
this really hot girl match with me and
she's interested in me she tells me to
just click this link and then like
follow the oh man this is just an upsell
like there's a bot it just upselling me
basically the other one is people that
um
uh like because like we did we were
joking about the poly thing but like
people have a lot of different like I
don't know preferences and kind of
different situations there's like a lot
more configurations than like a boy who
likes girls I'm a boy who likes boys
right like that's kind of what we knew
was like you know we were Checkers not
chess when it came to dating right there
was only so many moves you could make
you could move forward and backwards
that was it and so here you're red or
black that's that's the game yeah now
it's like you know multi-colored chess
and so the the way that uh my friend was
telling me he's like oh there's this one
app I think it was called field or
something like that maybe I got that
wrong but I think it's called field he's
like I like it because people just super
straight up it's like the culture on
that app is gonna be ultra direct it's
like I am looking for and you say the
exact thing you're looking for what
you're into and what you're not into so
that like people know like they're not
going to get meet somebody oh this
person's really cool but they want a
completely different type of
relationship configuration gender
configuration that I'm into and so uh so
I think you know there's there's always
a new need you know how when you and I
do meetups and every once in a while a
line will form to like say hi it's like
hey how are you uh I was joking with my
friend and she's like you know that's
what it feels like to be a hot chick all
the time but like like you know like
when you and I will have like an MFM
Meetup and we walk in you'll see like oh
people like are staring at us like this
guy's giving me energy like he wants to
like me to open I'll turn my hips a
little bit and let him like give them
like the the you know like Alex open my
hip that's what it is it's like whenever
you point your junk it's like you know
be out of fig and you're like one-on-one
with this other guy but you feel this
it's all dudes and you feel this other
loose energy you feel this other guy
hovering you're like all right I'll turn
my hips a little so this guy could get
in on the combo and uh that's basically
what it feels like to be like a a six
out of ten woman like all the time or
maybe even lower like just to be a woman
all the time just you just whatever you
want it's yours dude this last thing of
this do you remember like when I was in
college the the game was like you would
go to a bar or club or whatever and
literally it was like a physical version
of Tinder it was like you just go your
guys just go behind a girl and just
grind and if the girl like accepts the
grind then then you're you're in it they
don't it's like National Geography it's
like National Geographic man you're like
a bird reflecting its feathers the
craziest that's the craziest thing that
used to be normal I don't know if that's
still normal that's the craziest thing
that like I experienced in my life did
you do that I never did that that was so
uncomfortable dude that was all anybody
around me even knew like this
junk oh yeah no not a chance I was too
uncomfortable for that you had a
question on here that I actually was
thinking about the other day you have a
question on here and I I originally
thought I wrote this but I guess you did
where it's what's an example of things
today that our grandkids in 50 years
will think is absolutely insane I've
been thinking about this because on Tick
Tock and Instagram the kid's binding is
my example grinding at the club is my
first example
I don't know if they do that anymore or
not but it didn't even take 50 years it
took me 15 and I already realized that
was batshit crazy then well you'll see
these videos and they'll be of high
school so like the kids now will be like
check this out this is a home video of
the class of 2008 in high school and you
like see them walking around and like
you see like the the stuff that we used
to wear and you see like our razor flip
phones and then like the kids reminisce
like I can't believe they did this or
that was so much better this was so much
worse you had a cool question on here
about what do you think will be crazy
yeah I think about this a lot what are
things that 50 years from now like our
grandkids will look at the way we live
today
it'd be like what the hell were you
thinking right like
um you know there's past example like if
you go way past it's like slavery wow I
can't believe that was just like the way
you guys did things or whatever right
like you know riding horseback that's
crazy that's how people got around or
just like people just dying of like
everything you know like early on early
age like that's crazy that was so risky
to have a kid like you know one out of
what four or five kids would just die
before they even hit ten like that's
that's really really rough I was reading
this Lewis and Clark book and whenever
they get sick on the trail they like
give each other pills and they're like
we're just gonna give you diarrhea and
you're gonna [__] out the sickness
they call it a rush pill they go we're
gonna give you these pills and you're
gonna get tons of diarrhea and you're
gonna be healed and that was like the
thing it was just we're just gonna make
you poop a ton
yeah yeah we did that with four Loco it
was great
it just changes shape all right so so
you had you wrote someone here of more
recent history so he said driving to
places without Google Maps yeah I like
these are things that we experienced the
before and after right like we're at
that age where we experience the paper
map era the asking people for directions
era just knowing how the interstate
system of the United States works like
my dad just kind of knew roughly what
you do to Google Maps dude I don't even
know the highway I live in Austin I
don't even know the highway the big
Highway one mile away I can't even tell
you the name of it same I don't even
look up
go by field all right then you had
landlines versus Cell like landlines
being the only way to contact someone
versus cell phones we we both
experienced that
um you wrote unsafe cars what do you
mean by unsafe cars dude my first car
was in 1992 Mazda Protege and we bought
it for I got it for 900 for my mailman
and when you look at that yeah but I
know you're like I'll tell you well
sometimes uh we'd have to wear we'd have
to wear Ties on uh we'd have to wear
ties to school every once in a while and
if like my dad went to work too early
and he wasn't there my mailman would tie
my tie so like I got to know the mailman
a little bit kind of weird bought it
from bought my car from it for 900 and
if you see that car to a new brand new
like Honda Civic if you ever watch the
videos of them running into each other
it's insane it's absolutely insane like
the safety it's pretty wild how
dangerous they are so yeah I think like
these like uh when we look at cars uh
when I look at cars from like the 80s
and 90s it's ridiculous how shitty they
are yeah that's crazy
um so what are the ones that you think
50 years from now so we got a couple on
here let's just go back and forth you do
one I'll do one the first one is having
and I've said this for a while but
having like a growth on you having
something growing in your body that's
gonna kill you that you could have
figured out had you just gotten some
type of scan a year earlier so I think
that's gonna we're gonna look back and
like dude so you just had this thing in
your body and you didn't even know it'll
be like so how well how did you know
it's like well if you if you would feel
a lump then you would just go to the
doctors like feel Olympia like if
there's like a golf ball in you
that's new all right let me go get it
checked out that's literally state of
the art like I just described
state-of-the-art procedure and half the
time you're like yeah [__] it'll go away
you know what I mean
maybe it was that burger right earlier
yeah
go away it's probably a lipoma it'll go
away and so yeah I think that will be a
thing how about yours
um okay easy one I'll start easy mode
driving yourself like it's pretty clear
self-driving cars are like on the
horizon
the idea that like yeah back in my day
we used to get a license when we were 16
years old and then yeah I just used to
drive I used to just hold there we used
to have a steering wheel in the car and
you just have to look where you're going
and all the other cars were also holding
steering wheels looking where they were
going we tried not to crash and if
you're on a two-lane road it's 80 miles
an hour the opposite way with three feet
of distance yeah yeah you just well they
painted these lines you just had to stay
in the middle and you just had to keep
awake and stay in the middle let's keep
looking
and they'll be like what like that will
sound completely barbaric right like um
it's like did people not crash yeah they
sure did
that yeah some people get drunk before
they did it like it'll sound just like
what were you guys thinking well we just
didn't have the tag at the time but like
when you have self-driving cars
cars are going to drive perfectly
without you needing there won't even be
a steering wheel in the car cars will
become like entertainment pods you'll
just play video games or you'll sleep or
you'll watch movies or you'll work like
cars will become a whole different thing
very soon and there's a clear before and
after
another one is so different diets like
we still debate we're like the Atkins
diet that's a thing oh no no you want to
do the other thing where you got to eat
lots of carbs you know car whole grains
that's that's what you have to do and to
this day like we're like well which one
do you feel good on I don't know like
just do whatever I have alternated
carnivore and vegan twice
yeah you are vegan to your you will only
consume vegans it's just constantly
changed and like we don't know which one
necessarily is better you know there's
like really good Arguments for both and
we aren't sure and I think that that's
pretty insane that uh who knows you know
I don't know right by the way have you
ever do you know a lot of doctors do you
know how many classes they take on
nutrition typically it's like it's like
a class like they don't doctors don't
study nutrition which is pretty insane
uh or at least like your average like or
exercise yeah your average doctor
doesn't exactly it doesn't really know
too much about exercise or nutrition and
so I think that that's like something
we're gonna be like I don't know you
just kind of like tried a bunch of
different stuff and like you would read
a bunch of blog posts on it and listen
to podcasts and like you just kind of
guessed a little bit right I think
eating meat so killing animals to eat
their meat I think we'll be seen like a
genocide like a slavery I think it will
be seen as completely barbaric and
immoral 50 years from now when we have
the alternative there will be an
alternative which is basically
lab-grown meat or synthetic food that
will solve the kind of protein problems
and taste get the taste right
um and the cost right and at that when
that happens as that shift happens
we'll just be like yeah people just you
just take the thing you Slaughter it you
just kill it and then you eat it and
then be like you do it yourself like no
no gross I would never do that
they do it and then they package it and
then we read it and they're like what
like didn't you have a dog it's like
yeah I would never do that to a dog
it's like but you would do it to this
other animal I was like yeah
I was like how did you guys decide it's
like well
I guess I'm a cuteness or like I don't
know I don't know how we decided what
was completely illegal and immoral and
would get you canceled versus like you
eat it two times a day like you know the
line is very thin between like cow and
chicken and dog right like it's not that
it's not that clear why one yes first
the other no
um so I think that eating meat will
become will be seen as as basically like
Our Generations we just committed
genocide on animals I have 20 cows at my
Ranch you knew that right that have cows
out there they're not yours right
they're just straight or they're yours
they're my neighbor their my neighbor
owns them and they are allowed to use my
land to graze and I don't pay taxes
because of that or I pay less taxes but
basically uh you I get to know them so
like I know who they are like I know
which ones are which I know whose mom is
who and like it [__] sucked our first
week there that we bought the place uh
like a four month year old calf died or
it was but a four-month-old calf is
still like 600 pounds or whatever it was
it was like a 600 pound baby and
apparently it like swallowed a golf ball
so my neighbor was like hey were you
hitting golf balls I was like no dude I
was like I just I just moved here and it
wasn't me I don't know
um on Instagram
yeah and I was like dude once you get to
know me you'll you'll we'll understand
neither of us to golfer I'm not a golfer
you know what I mean and so and then I
was like hey uh Jeff this guy was I was
like what do I go and get like a shovel
or something he goes oh no that some
[__] is going to be gone in three days
he's like what do you mean he goes
you'll see and so I come back in three
days and the whole body and carcass
everything was gone the all the animals
like the birds and Hogs they just ate it
it was completely gone and the mother
would go back to the spot where that
calf was and would like mourn and I was
like my heart was broken I was like I
don't know if I could eat meat in the
same way now so I felt like devastated
and so since then I basically I only eat
red meat like once I'm month because the
cow is like I get to know them and I'm
like I feel too sad I can't do it I'm
not I'm not I'm not that manly of a man
I can't do it but you you think that
child birthing manually is gonna be a
thing of the past
yeah so uh when I was in LA we had
dinner with a person named Jessica Ma
you know she is yeah she's uh she's very
impressive she's super impressive I
think she did a company called in dinero
I don't know her very well she's at this
dinner but she was on the other side
table so I didn't get to know her too
much but uh she seemed very interesting
like in dinero was like an accounting
company that's still very successful but
I think it's so successful now that she
just has tons of money and does more
stuff yeah it's a big one I think she's
she's out of that business now from what
it sounded like um and we were like what
do you do and she's like oh I basically
invest and incubate like uh like hard
science
businesses and I think she's still only
like 29. yeah yeah it was she was very
very impressive sometimes you could just
tell that people are playing a different
game at a different level so there's
like yeah same game different level
different game same level and then
there's different game different level I
would put her in different game
different levels yeah you could talk to
her she's pretty brilliant I'm within
five minutes you're like oh okay I think
she was I think her she started in
dinero an accounting software company at
19. I don't know much about her but she
started her I just went to her LinkedIn
by the way uh started her first six
figure business when she was in Middle
School
goddamn different game different level
okay yeah
I was
I hadn't even grinded yet
yeah
that's crazy
um anyways so she's she's doing this
thing um
one of the things we said we were
talking to her but we were like what are
some of the crazy science things that
you're funding and then she would say
things that were like her thing was like
novel like she's trying to find like a
novel approach
at like an existing thing I don't want
to butcher it but something like that
which basically like what you called a
bold a bold uh bold science so it's like
basically like someone taking a new
scientific Approach at an existing
problem so she'll go to universities and
she'll find
um research Labs where they'll be like
this is the one researcher who's trying
to do this thing but this like
completely other way than the general
field is going and she's like cool I
want to fund that because those bold
approaches when they work work in a
really big way
and um
so one of the things we talked about
just somehow in the conversation came up
was like uh like birthing a child is
like the natural way or whatever like
you know a woman carries baby nine
months it goes into labor delivers baby
um you know
dad Snips the umbilical cord like that's
the the process as we know it today wait
does the dad do it they they hear like
Dad you want to do it you gotta be ready
is that whatever be offered I'm not
doing that on them in the moment they're
like Dad come do this and you're gonna
be like what no I'm good I'm
I'm holding her hand over here I'm I'm
busy and they'll be like no no come come
do it and then you're gonna be like oh
and you're gonna hold the thing and be
like I don't want to hurt this is gonna
hurt what is this yeah I'm not doing
that man I don't even want to I won't
even trim our toenails I'm not gonna
touch that
I don't want to touch that thing you're
did you do it I did it yeah oh man I
don't the peer pressure of six doctors
and your wife who just like did a modern
Miracle did a like act of human bravery
and courage and then you're like I don't
feel comfortable doing this like dude I
am not doing that wimp of the year like
I've already told my wife I think I'm
gonna pass out I'm thinking a couple
Xanaxes in in the room I I this is on no
that's too much for me man I don't know
if I can do that I'm I'm not one of that
guys I'm not that guy I don't think my
brother-in-law with my sister was uh you
haven't given having birth giving birth
whatever yeah she he like yawned at some
point
are you tired
he was like no sorry he's like no it's
just boring
yeah it is honestly kind of boring
um but yeah anyways yeah you better be
prepared you're gonna have to do it
um
so anyways birthing a child so she was
like yeah I think that's gonna be seen
as like unnecessary sort of barbaric
um not like as like
um scientifically sound as like
eventually we'll be able to kind of like
almost like incubate the baby
um and just like deliver the baby
through
like essentially a machine that the a
baby will be sort of like grown and
delivered that way have you met someone
who's had a surrogate yeah many people
haven't had surrogate yeah I have and
they've acknowledge that they don't feel
they didn't love the kid the same as the
other one
pretty first of all did you ask of
course I asked of Cora is that not the
that's not that's obviously the first
thing you're gonna ask when you hear
about it well there's like a there's
like a handful of questions
there's a handful of questions which is
a like obviously how much does that cost
uh you're gonna run yet yeah other women
yeah where'd you find them uh and then
like what did you do like what was the
relationship like and then like my
fourth question is like
did they ever try to hold the baby
hostage dude I could still imagine you
being the worst possible surrogate
because you would micromanage their
lifestyle like it's my baby in there
yeah you better you better get up here
on this treadmill but the surrogate can
basically hold you hostage right because
you'll do anything you'll do like well
yeah whatever you want like I'm I I have
to give you what you want because I will
do anything for that kid but then the
last the fifth question was like all
right but like did you love the kid as
much as the other ones and the answer
was at first no definitely not I
definitely didn't uh they got honest
with me and I so I don't know if I
believe this is gonna be a thing
um but yeah I feel like if there's the
option it's kind of like the epidural
um like
so I think when we were in the hospital
so my wife's insane and wants to only do
natural birth and like feel all the pain
for no reason but she's like you know
she's like that's how I get down I'm
like oh wow oh my God
or so I guess opposites
I've taken the light version
you
[Laughter]
got any leftovers I'll take it
but the doctor had said 90 she's like 85
to 90 of the patients in their hospital
do the epidural because like you know it
makes sense like if you can
you know not feel that level of pain
it's it's easy to see why somebody would
choose that so um you know if you just
sort of extrapolate from there you're
like cool would you like to also not
have the nine months of pregnancy like
going on in your body
um if there was that option like you
really think people wouldn't take it I
think people would take it yeah I think
some people would I just don't I don't
know if it's look at the ozempic thing
dude if you give people the magic pill
the way out like people take that [__]
like if you get the cost right that's a
good point I do love people are going to
avoid pain right they're going to avoid
discomfort and pain where they can I
order doordash three times a day like
you think that people aren't gonna do
this they're gonna yeah you're right
actually I love magic pills whenever I
hear someone that's who's selling like a
magical cure or a magic pill I'm I'm in
probably won't work but tell me
everything
oh zepik is a little bit of a magic pill
when I when I was taking it it was quite
magical did you take it no no I haven't
taken it you should it's awesome I guess
I'm also kind of crazy in that way where
I'm like well then it wouldn't be as
satisfying like I want to do this on my
own yeah yeah but having ABS is pretty
sick so totally agree
two or three failed diets away from from
breaking and going on this epic um um
all right what else we got that's all I
got yeah that's it all right we're out
of here Sam hit him with the line that
is the pod
[Music]
foreign